I've been interested in the idea of
business ever since I got my first Iron
Man comic which was sometime in the
early 90s oh yeah I was a fan of Iron
Man before it was cool
I always thought Iron Man was awesome
because Tony Stark was a character who
was as interesting as Iron Man himself
he had this business that he ran he
looked cool he was suave sophisticated
he was a genius and that really appealed
to me I loved the idea of being really
important of running this big business
it's not answering to anyone and of
being my own boss what I discovered as I
got older was that I don't naturally
lend myself to a corporate environment
I'm not someone who takes orders very
well I'm not someone who likes to be
boxed in I'm probably a creative type
hence why I've ended up making videos
and running a website but I didn't mean
I didn't also want to build my way up
and have my own business in fact I want
to go straight to the top and that was
part of the problem I didn't want to
climb the corporate ladder I just want
to start doing business in my own way
and as it turned out as I got old enough
thanks to the internet that would be
possible and that's also why I decided
to become an entrepreneur I set up my
own online business as a freelance
writer I learned to program and became
an app developer and I work with Android
Authority as a presenter which has all
been really awesome and giving me the
freedom and the time and the flexibility
that I need to work out properly and not
be too burned out and maybe you're
interested in starting your own business
so that you can spend more time on the
things that matter to you whether that's
spending time with family whether it's
working on side projects whether it's
staying in shape or whether it's
traveling the world and working as you
go on a little laptop ever notice how
Batman doesn't work a stressful
nine-to-five it just wouldn't work I've
been able to just fit work around my
wife instead of the other way around
and it's something that I highly
recommend to everyone and yeah this is
something that more and more people are
doing now in fact it's got a new name is
called the gig economy because people
are realizing that thanks to the
Internet this is possible and there's
lots of ways that you can start earning
an income from the web and build up
enough of a stable and secure income
that you can safely leave your
nine-to-five job and that's why I want
to share with you in this video to some
people the term gig economy is more
synonymous with these kind of short-term
working for a business for asset agreed
amount of time or four until the
completion of a certain project and this
is something that's got a bit more of a
bad reputation and people look at it
similar to you know zero hour contracts
and things because it is inherently
rather unstable it's less stable it's
less secure than a full-time contract or
even freelancing the way that I'm
suggesting so here you're gonna work
full-time for a company for a set period
of time then once that's up you've then
got to quickly find another gig and
until you do you're not earning any
income so to me that's a less effective
or less appealing way of being part of
the seeking economy of being a
freelancer but of course that's not
Shinto of you further and I'm sure
there's many perks to that I'm sure
there's many ways you can get to work
the way I did it is to predominantly
become a freelance writer that's at
least how I started out I went on to
forums specifically I went on to do to a
point forum more recently I've used
warrior forum and black hat world these
are forms where people who own websites
and who market websites meet and talk
and of course they need people to write
for them so that they have something to
offer on their website of course when
you google something you find content
and as a writer I supply that content so
I was able to find people that needed to
work another place you can find work
like this is up work
another one is people per hour
freelancers calm even fiver on five of
the whole idea is that you sell things
for five dollars but what you can do it
to say I'll write you a sentence for
five dollars and then you charge more if
people want more than that knowing how
to market yourself and promote yourself
is crucial here sell yourself by talking
about previous work and by mentioning
all the things your clients will be
looking for reliable delivery better
quality originality quick turnaround etc
the quality of your pitch in these
adverts will greatly define your success
going forwards try and focus on the
value proposition what is it that you're
actually offering to them ultimately
that's normally going to mean things
like better customer satisfaction higher
profits more turnaround greater footfall
so point out how the skills that you
have will help them to accomplish their
business goals
first I had lots of clients on the go
boy I actually found in the end was that
what suited me was to find an agency a
guy who would sell my work for me
keeping a finder's fee so I didn't earn
as much but it matters not have to deal
with all the admin all the
back-and-forth emails and so I set
myself my own salary and a target salary
that had to earn every single day and
this guy he would find the work so I had
a stable income that way and I just
supply him with the work make sure I did
my minimum amount every day and then I'd
know I'd earn at least that minimum wage
and then on the side I could find other
clients and this way was quite stable
and you need lots of different clients
have lots of different kinds and types
so I had clients who would accept work
whenever I had it I had clients that
wanted just small bits every now and
then drip-feed I had clients that paid
more but wanted less frequent work and I
had clients who paid less but provided
me with the frequency so this allowed me
to do as much work as I needed to and
I've never really had a dry spell and of
course the more experience you can get
the more you can get your work on big
websites you can then show that and you
can start to increase your salary if
you're not a writer then don't worry you
can sell all sorts of other things you
can be a proofreader you can be a web
designer you can be a programmer you can
be a photographer you can be a presenter
on YouTube you can be an editor video
editor you can be someone who does SEO
there's so many different options and it
doesn't even have to be related to the
web you could be a lawyer online I had a
friend who set himself up lots of
different websites that's another way
you can find clients by the way so set
yourself up websites so you've got a
portfolio you can show off anyways this
friendly end websites selling all kinds
of different gigs that he would do so he
would go and catch fish in people that
who had over populations and then sell
them on one day and then on another day
he might do SEO for somebody search
engine optimization so you can pursue
all these different things that interest
you and the main difficult thing is to
manage those clients and all that
different work coming in to make sure
that you have enough when it's a dry
spell but you don't overload yourself
and become overworked and overstressed
and that comes down to the way that you
the clients that you pick you have to
learn to turn down clients if a client
wants to be difficult if a client wants
to have long conversations with you
about every single little piece of work
that they offer then I often find it's
easier to just say look I'm sorry it
seemed great but how about you find
those services somewhere else here's
something I can recommend for you if
someone just wants the work just sends
you the money as soon as it's done those
are the kind of clients you want that's
what's going to make our lives a lot
easier and then you need to be strict
with yourself like I said if you can
find some kind of recurring work that's
going to help an awful lot and at the
same time you can find work that you can
drip feed the best kind of work is work
that'll take your writing or your art or
your design whenever you make it and
these things exist as well one of the
hardest things is negotiating salary
just as bad as having a difficult client
is taking on too much work at a cheap
price my first tip of that is don't
undervalue yourself you're worth a lot
more than you probably think you are
also drive a hard bargain and be willing
to walk away you can always advertise to
try and find higher paid work even if
you have enough work at your current
rate and that way if they don't accept
it doesn't matter and if they do accept
you can then get your clients to enter a
kind of bidding war to see who gets to
keep you if you want to stick with your
current clients but increase your rates
this is the trickiest thing to do and my
biggest tip here is to find a way to
offer more value for what you're doing
so as a writer in the past I've done
this by saying I'll do an extra
proofread or I'll do more formatting or
I'll work extra hours and you can
explain how you're increasing the value
of what you're offering then you can
charge more another option is to sell
your workers packages so you could have
a premium option for people who want
double proofreading greater time spent
on your work more formatting and then
you could have a basic range and you'll
find that a lot of people are going to
want the premium package and of course
it can supplement your income in a whole
bunch of different ways you can do
part-time work so you could work
part-time in a shop in fact I've heard
some people say that this is an almost a
necessity I personally disagree
massively I think you can do you can
more than make up enough money just by
doing freelance work but of course if
you want a little bit of extra security
then doing part-time work is an option
another thing you can do
that performs of passive incomes this is
income you make when you're not doing
any work say wash your sleepy moss
you're on holiday examples of course
include things like selling apps which
sell whether or not I'm promoting them
having a YouTube channel and having
adverts on there so people watch this
and only money even when I'm not working
so having that passive income provides
another backup source of money likewise
you could take photos and sell them on
stock photography websites or you could
create assets for unity and sell them on
there I also have a book published and
I'm in talks to start publishing another
one so that's another form of work and I
also have a part-time contract part-time
agreement with Android Authority where I
work for them two days a weeks but out
over for day so that's another form of
income another form of you know choosing
what kind of work works for you rather
than the other way around so you can
pick and choose different jobs different
gigs and then create something that
works for you
another thing you think about is your
outgoings because when you're a
freelancer you think about money in an
entirely different way because you
realize just how much you're trading
time for income so if you take a day off
to hang out with your friends often
finish now early you're actually losing
how much money you would have learnt
earned in that hour and likewise I
sometimes think well if I buy this thing
then I can work a little bit extra and
then earn it so I haven't really paid
for it you know I haven't really I don't
need to consider it as part of my budget
but at the same time I might think well
if I don't buy this thing I was going to
buy then I could finish work an hour
earlier so again you have to really
think about how much money you need to
live how much money you want and then
design your business around that and the
amount of time you're working because of
course you can set your own hours you
can choose how much work you have this
is all great but it is also pressure you
need to be disciplined with yourself so
I always finish enough money that I'm
earning enough to live off and then on
top of that I aim for I have like a
minimum that I try to earn and then I
have an optimum that I try and earn and
I have a shoot for the stars I try now
but at the same time I also see the
value of R&D research and development so
learning new skills building projects
like this one learning programming
learning video editing better all these
things from having to charge more on the
future and to create new revenue streams
so again it's all open to interpret
tation but if you choose the right
clients if you juggle them correctly and
like I say if you ditch the ones that
are taking up more time than they're
worth
I call that communication overhead well
I didn't call it that it's called that
communication overhead is all the time
you waste on emails and things if you
can keep that to a minimum and just work
then this is a very stable way to earn
your money some of my clients I've been
with me for years and they provide me
with steady income all that time I have
income streams from my apps from YouTube
that aren't gonna go anywhere overnight
so actually in some ways being a
freelancer is more stable than being
employed because I'm never gonna lose
all of my income if you're fired if your
business goes under then you're gonna
lose all your money but if you have your
finger and lots of pies if your business
is a freelance business and you do all
sorts of different things if you're a
sole trader like me I mean what the
chance is that all my clients are gonna
say they don't need me anymore
and then at the same time I am so going
to stop making money and YouTube's gonna
stop making money all I have to do is as
soon as I lose one of those big clients
I start looking for others long-term
clients is probably one of the secrets
to making this work for you and of
course this is where the other crucial
aspects of running an online business
comes in if you're going to do this in
the long term
you need to be good at what you do need
to be reliable you need to stick to
deadlines maintain communication with
your clients and ensure the businesses
know they can rely on you you're good to
my wife I will stay with you yes that's
one of the biggest problems when trying
to find online freelancers and that's
where you'll stand out against the crowd
it's the only way you'll get clients to
want to stick around and the only way
you can build your contacts list and
it's the only way you'll get recommended
to other clients too and another way you
can benefit from this kind of work from
this gig economy is by not necessarily
being a full time freelancer but by
earning money on the side so if you've
got a job you like but you're not
earning quite enough money then why not
do some work in the evenings on the
commute home even you can start to
supplement your income that way once
again it's just seeing that your income
isn't tied to your salary salary income
aren't the same and income and wealth
certainly aren't the same and that's how
you need to think if you want to design
the lifestyle you want and the business
that you want
likewise you can also use freelancing
and gigging as a way to transition
between jobs and in particular if you
lose a job or something then this is a
great way to tide you over until you
find another job and if you're
interested in becoming a freelancer or
entering the gig economy and you
currently work a 9 to 5 then the way to
do that is to first do a little bit of
work in the evenings or even on your
commute home and then just sell it
online when you get back and then to
increase that gradually eventually might
be able to drop a day of work in your
office maybe work four days a week maybe
eventually go part-time and then only
once you've got a stable income and
you're sure it works can you give up
your full-time job this isn't a risky
venture you don't have to just quit your
job I'm quitting and then hope you find
the work online you can make sure it
works and then quit your job although to
be honest there is a lot of work out
there as long as you are skilled do
develop the skills as long as you're
dedicated as long as you work hard and
then you put yourself out there you know
how to market yourself and sell those
skills then there's enough work out
there that I think you really don't need
to worry actually if you've you've asked
in the past that I talked about some of
the books I have here beside me
certainly there are a lot of great books
that I can recommend if you want to get
into freelancing and working online one
such book is the 4-hour workweek by Tim
Ferriss
that's a fantastic one it tells you how
to better manage your work-life balance
how to lower the amount of time you're
working whilst getting more profit from
that time and fortunately that's a book
that's missing from my collection right
now as I lent it out and never got it
back the bastards another great one that
I do have here is the personal MBA by
Josh Kaufman this is an MBA in a book so
it attempts to teach you everything you
need to know about running a business
and it does a pretty admirable job of
that I highly recommend this one as a
way to learn the basics I also picked up
a few tips from Richard Branson's book
but more excitingly and more importantly
stay tuned because I've just signed a
contract to write my next book which is
going to be all about navigating the gig
economy and working online as a
freelancer so sometime next year that
will be available and I'll be sure to
update you about that then so yeah
really the aim of this video was just to
demonstrate that you can start to view
your work and your lifestyle slightly
differently not so quicker this is work
this is
because sometimes you can work on
projects that end up earning money and
you don't have to say I'm gonna work
these set hours you can work
whichever hours you want to put out
throughout the day spread out throughout
the week I've actually ended up taking
Monday's off and working harder Tuesday
to Friday I use Mondays now just to work
on the bionaire which I believe in the
future could earn me a fair amount of
money possibly a full-time income so
this is the way you've got to think you
don't have to be black and white this is
what I work this is what I'm done this
is my salary instead you can pick and
choose jobs manage them as you like deal
with those difficult clients get rid of
the ones that are too difficult find the
ones that are long-term develop your
skills and then that way you can design
what you want work to look like you can
pursue the things you find interesting
you can create the time to spend with
family friends hobbies and for me
personally I just think is a better way
of living and it's not for everyone but
maybe you do as well and hopefully this
videos inspired you to at least give it
a try let me know in the comments down
below if you have any questions or if
you'd like to see more videos on this
topic thanks a ton for watching guys
fans video useful please leave a like
please share around
like I say comment down below subscribe
to the channel if you want more on this
on productivity on technology but also
fitness bodybuilding biohacking
transhumanism nootropics all the usual
stuff if that sounds good then thanks a
ton for watching and I'll see you next
time bye for now